let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right as mentioned uh dueling town
halls last night i
i thought trump performed pretty well
despite
the extremely aggressive moderating if
we can call it that by savannah guthrie
on nbc
uh once again of course trump trump gets
the kind of hostile questioning
that joe biden has never ever received
and will never ever receive
but i thought trump was disciplined calm
focused
i thought it was good i would love to
see we talked about this yesterday i
would love to see this version of trump
and only this at least until election
day that's what i would love to see
i don't expect it but that's what i
would like because i thought it was it
was
uh very effective and what that meant
is the left had to go elsewhere for
controversy because they couldn't get it
from trump
and so they decided to focus instead on
a woman sitting behind trump
who was nodding yes this was their focus
a woman nodding she was the target of
leftist rage
uh and here she is you can see her there
nodding look at her with her nodding
how dare you who are you to nod
who do you think you are nodding this is
this is what
you can go to twitter and type in
nodding okay and search for it and
you'll see hundreds of tweets from
people condemning
the nodding woman and trying to dox her
find out who she is punish her for
nodding liz uh garbass for example liz
garvis a
a hollywood person i don't know some
kind of actress or something
she confessed to feeling quote a lot of
rage
about the woman nodding can you imagine
can you just you know i
i continue to be so impressed
by the ability of many of these leftists
to get angry about stuff
especially when i get angry about things
all the time
you know that's my thing i get but even
i i'm left in
in awe in admiration of their ability to
get angry because
they get angry about things that i
wouldn't even dream i couldn't even
conceive of being angry about them i
don't know how to do it
they need to teach me they've achieved a
level of
of petty anger anger that is that is uh
you know it makes me look
like an absolute novice in comparison so
i can't imagine
watching a town hall and just sitting
there stewing
look at her nodding stop nodding
i can't i just i wouldn't be able to do
it i can't understand it but
this is what rage i feel rage
that the woman was nodding tom nichols
um called for journalists to find this
woman
uh find out who she is and punish her he
didn't say punisher but that was
implied in fact tom nichols as you can
see
look at this he tweeted angrily about
the nodding woman
dozens of times he spent hours
without a hint of irony this was not
performance art this was he was
really this this is how he decided to
spend his thursday night
finding out who the woman is who nodded
at trump
and destroy her then the media started
doing news articles about it
um until finally she was identified they
they succeeded in finding out who she
was and they identified her and
um and but you know the thing that set
them off obviously
is it's not just that a person was
nodding now if that was like
a white guy behind their nodding then i
think they probably would say nothing
about it
it's that she's a black woman how dare a
black woman
indicate any sort of agreement towards
trump
she's not allowed to it's not permitted
this is the leftist mentality
black people are ours
women are ours latinos
racial minorities they belong to us
you belong to us is the message that the
left sends to people in those
demographics
uh they think they own them and if if if
they stray
if they get out of line if they
misbehave well the left is going to
punish them severely for it
this is the mentality it's sick it's
twisted it's deranged it's
it's crazy um
the way they react it's like it's like
they they really do react
like they have been personally betrayed
when a black person black woman
especially
because now you have the intersection
you got two two intersectional points
here
black woman um indicates at all that
that she might not be a leftist
they react as though they have been
personally stabbed in the back
and betrayed by like that person owes
them
something and they are not getting what
they are owed
number two how about some positive news
for a change um honestly this news
made me very happy just wonderful stuff
here from the daily wire it says
enrollment rates have declined for
undergraduate students at colleges and
universities across the united states
and much of it can be attributed to
fewer freshmen choosing to attend
according to a new study released on
thursday figures from the national
student clearinghouse research center
center show that
uh first-year students have enrolled in
colleges at a 16
lower rate than first years in 2019.
this group of students account for 69 of
the total decline in the national
undergraduate enrollment rate
a figure that currently stands at a four
percent decline
the data also shows that community
colleges have been particularly affected
by the decline experiencing roughly
23 drop enrollment rates um
doug shapiro executive director of the
center uh of uh
what center some center i just talked
about oh the national student
clearinghouse
told the new york times in an interview
that community college enrollment during
the great recession actually increased
and called the declining rate 2020
enrollment
data staggering i fear that many of
those students will never go back
well look i got nothing against
community college so
uh this is uh i think community college
has a real role
so this is nothing against them but as
far as the four year universities
experiencing this drop we can only pray
it continues
and uh and that many of them are
bankrupted and destroyed
that's my dream scenario dozens and
dozens of these god forsaken
institutions
boarded up abandoned and we can all
gather
and hold hands in a circle around the
abandoned buildings
dancing dancing the night away
that's that is my that is my fantasy
um and why would i feel that way about
them well you know no reason
except that these institutions are
financially bankrupting
generations of americans forcing them
not forcing them but duping them into
paying
for the privilege of being brainwashed
in exchange for being made poor and in
debt
they'll also make you confused and
deluded that's the deal and so
yeah um yeah i i would uh
i'm a big fan of the idea of of them
suffering
enormous financial consequences for that
now number three let's move on to this
from the daily wire here's a story to
prove my point about the last thing we
just talked about
says the university of minnesota's
school of social work and continuing
education series recently hosted what
they called
a special webinar series that was titled
quote
deconstructing and decentralizing
whiteness in practice
a three-part series in which a lecture
titled
recovery from white conditioning taught
white people how to use a 12-step
program similar to alcoholics anonymous
to recover and reclaim our full humanity
okay um i can't even read any more of
this so it's a 12-step program to
overcome
being white i know we're so used to this
by now that we're numb to it but
let's really focus on the fact that they
are treating whiteness
like a literal disease like a sickness
and they're doing this while claiming
that there's no racism against white
people
no there's no racism against white
people you diseased demons
that's the message number four stevie
nicks of fleetwood mac
enjoying a bit of a career resurgence
because of that video of the guy
skateboarding and drinking juice
that's all it takes these days has now
come out and credited her her career
success
with her decision to murder her unborn
child
uh in a recent interview she says quote
abortion rights that was really my
generation's fight if president trump
wins this election
and puts the judge and he wants she will
absolutely outlaw it
and push women back into back alley
abortions
side note by the way the supreme court
is not going to be outlawing abortion if
they
overturn roe v wade then it goes to the
states and it will still remain legal in
many states
you know california and new york many of
the most popular states will remain
legal in
uh anyway if i had if i had not had that
abortion i'm pretty sure
that there would have been no fleetwood
mac
perish the thought there's just no way
that i could have had a child then
working as hard as i worked constantly
and there were a lot of drugs i was
doing a lot of drugs
i would have had to walk away and i knew
that the music we were going to bring to
the world
was going to heal so many people's
hearts and make people happy
and i thought you know what that's
really important there's not another
band in the world that has two lead
women singers two lead women writers
that was my
world's mission
you know i have to say there are no good
reasons to kill a child
ever period but this reason
that you had to kill a child in order to
ensure that the world is not deprived of
fleetwood mac
this has to be perhaps at the top of the
list of the really bad reasons
she's saying she killed her child so she
could do drugs and make money
i'm sorry work hard and i like how she
lumps in
you know i was working so hard back then
uh and doing a lot of drugs
working hard and doing drugs somehow to
me those seem like mutually exclusive
pursuits don't they either you're at a
point your life or you're doing a lot of
drugs
or you're at a point where you're
working hard it doesn't seem likely that
you're doing both
but regardless um that's why she killed
her child
how do you think she's feeling about
that decision now
i know how she pretends to feel but how
does she actually feel she's 72 years
old
childless alone not married has no
children
plenty of money sure and uh some hit
records all of which are decades old
does the money keep her company on those
long cold
nights well the song she she's already
sung a million times
give her comfort as she lives out her
final years on this earth
it's just impossible to believe that a
woman at this stage of life
would still feel great about killing the
only child she ever had
for for for success that's now gone and
fame that has faded
and fun times that are all mostly in the
past now it's just there's no way
you are alone
with your past success being your only
legacy
i mean who cares about fleetwood mac who
cares about fleetwood mac now
who's going to care about fleetwood mac
50 years from now
i don't know about you but but i i know
how she feels about it
i would trade fleetwood max music in a
heartbeat for her child
if i could number five dr fauci now says
that we may have to bite the bullet this
year and
sacrifice thanksgiving this is him
talking about that listen
of course that's such a sacred part of
american
tradition the family gathering around
thanksgiving but
that is a risk you may have to bite the
bullet and sacrifice that social
gathering
unless you're pretty certain that the
people
that you're dealing with are not
infected okay in fairness you did have
that qualifier there he says can't
cancel thanksgiving unless you're sure
nobody is sick
but there's always that vagueness to it
right uh and then it comes and
then and then and then eventually it's
no no it's banned never mind so that's
the way it's always worked like 15
minutes
or 15 minutes might as well they might
as well 50 15 days to slow the spread
they said hey it's only 15 days you know
give or take this is fifty maybe fifteen
days
oh but dr fatchi what happens after 15
days well you know we'll see
we'll see i well it's you know it's it's
it could be done at 15 days who knows
i know this tactic because i use it with
my kids
and they're finally starting to catch on
that if they ask me for something and i
give them the
maybe we'll see sure i mean maybe yeah
maybe
and then i especially if i add the
qualifier uh maybe yeah
you know it's if there's time at the end
of the day uh to get ice cream well
we we might do that sure maybe that
they've realized that that's just a no
that is a no in gestation that is no in
its embryonic
phase um and that's uh that's what we're
getting from factory
but in this case the good thing is you
know that
i don't personally give a damn about
fauci's opinion
of my thanksgiving plans it makes no
difference to me i'm not canceling
thanksgiving i'm gonna have thanksgiving
it's my favorite holiday
because there and i'll tell you why it's
my favorite very simple lots of food
no presents i don't have to give
presents i don't have to receive them
which is also a great burden for me
because i have to pretend that i like it
all the presents i get
um it just get rid of all that and just
get right to the food
that's all i care about these days when
your child holidays are about presents
when you're an adult it's really just
about the food that's
who cares about the present um so it's
my favorite holiday i'm not gonna be
canceling it
and uh we're gonna be having
thanksgiving we will not be wearing
masks
and we will not be practicing social
distancing uh and we're just gonna be
you know we're gonna be normal people
having a thanksgiving celebration
and but you know in fact i'm not gonna
be forcing anyone to attend that's the
other good thing so
i i was i'm not gonna go and abduct
anybody off the street
and and make them sit at my table uh you
know under threat of
under threat of murder with a gun
pointed to their head and stuff
cranberry
sauce down their throat i'm not gonna do
that we will hold off on that aspect
of our normal tradition this year which
means that
anyone who's at thanksgiving with me
they chose to be there
they chose to take on the risk which i
think is is not a
very enormous risk but they chose to
take on that risk for the sake of turkey
and gravy and i think
it is a gamble worth taking personally
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content